you know I've been thinking about it and
I think this film contains the funniest
end credits sequence I've ever seen in a
movie 22 Jump Street is directed by Phil
Lord and Christopher Miller coming fresh
off the success of the lego movie and it
stars once again Channing Tatum and
Jonah Hill back from the first film that
was an adaptation of the TV show from
the 80s a very loose adaptation last
time they went to high school this time
they're going to college again to
investigate drugs being spread around
the school this is a film that is very
self-aware very meta very self
referential and it makes fun of itself
the genre of comedies the genre of
action films and movies in general and
it does a great job doing it 21 Jump
Street was a huge surprise when it came
out because almost everyone thought that
movie was gonna be really terrible but
it wasn't it was actually very hilarious
and very clever and going into this
movie I was thinking to myself are they
gonna be able to capture that lightning
in a bottle again are they gonna be able
to be surprising again and they actually
are because I think this one is a little
bit better than the first one that's a
very rare thing to have a sequel that's
actually better than the first one in
fact there is a character in this film
that acknowledges that as someone stays
around for a long time they generally
get worse and worse and worse at what
they're trying to do another self
referential joke about sequels one of
the things I was very pleased with after
seeing this film was realizing that the
trailers didn't really give away any of
the best jokes in fact I remember
watching the trailers thinking that
looks okay kind of funny but it didn't
really look that mind-blowingly
hilarious I think they use the exact
same strategy they used for 21 Jump
Street by not showing all the best parts
in the trailers and having people be
really surprised by how funny the movie
actually was because the same thing
happened this one I walk in this film
and a lot of jokes hit quite a bit of
stuff in this movie had me belly
laughing and the chemistry between Jonah
Hill and Channing Tatum is once again
excellent and Ice Cube has a very good
scene in this movie that really had me
rolling
this is the best Ice Cube has been since
21 Jump Street but I must stress the
best part of this movie in my opinion is
that it is so self-aware of itself and
very self-deprecating it makes fun of
itself quite often there are a lot of
great lines throughout the action
sequences that take place during this
movie that make fun of action movies
that really were smart and clever
there's a character in this film that
plays
a roommate to one of Jonah Hill's
friends in the film and she has a very
one joke performance her entire
performance is all about this one joke
that Jonah Hill looks older than he is I
didn't really laugh that much the first
time she made the joke and as it
continued to go on from seeing the scene
to seeing your old your wrinkly I get it
you think Jonah Hill looks older than a
freshman it just didn't really work for
me and her character got kind of
annoying I do think they handled the
action sequences better in the sequel
than they did the first time around I
actually was invested in some of the
action sequences there are a few draggy
parts throughout the movie where laughs
are a little bit inconsistent and some
things fall flat but for the most part I
thought 22 Jump Street was better than
the first one
I love the chemistry between the stars
there were a lot of great jokes in the
movie and it had a great way of making
fun of itself I'm gonna give 22 Jump
Street at b-plus I know that's a great
they gave the first one you're gonna be
wondering why I didn't give it a a -
since I said it was better look it's
better but I'm still giving them to B+
because that's how I feel about the
movie guys I'm interested in knowing
what you thought of this film when it
comes out or if you've seen the film
already it's definitely one of the
funnier comedies we've had in a while
and be sure to stay for the end credits
because not only during the end credits
is there some really hilarious stuff but
there is a scene afterwards to stick
around for it also I really hope you
watched my recent video called on film
criticism I covered quite a bit of
questions that I've gotten for a long
time I talked about the art of reviewing
movies and I had some awesome guest
stars like schmoes know Jeremy Jones
Scott Mane's from Access Hollywood
please check that out if you haven't
already because I'd love to hear your
guys thoughts thanks as always for
watching guys and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck my
nice
[Music]